[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 29 mars bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sûreté des soixante
dix huit si vous nous rejoignez à 18
heures nous sommes en direct depuis le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout de suite
les titres de cette édition
l'enceinte saint-quentinoise qui reçoit
aujourd'hui la première édition d' en
piste pour l'emploi 12 heures pour
découvrir des métiers ou encore
décrocher un entretien d'embauché et
demi l'offre de travail à la clé nous en
parlons dans un instant avec notre
invité
il a fermé ses portes en 2007 l'ancien
collège bergson à montigny-le-bretonneux
va être totalement déconstruit est les
travaux ont débuté il ya peu en lieu et
place de l'établissement 136 logements
seront érigées ainsi qu'un nouveau pôle
culturel
reportage à suivre et puis cette
compétition sera diffusée sur tv 60,18
la coupe du monde de bmx supercross
débarque à saint quentin en yvelines est
les deux premières manches se déroule
samedi et dimanche juste à côté du
vélodrome sur le stadium internationale
invitée de ce journal michel callot
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme
je me dirige tout de suite à la table
avec mon invité à roanne le gala bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes délégué communautaire
en charge de l'emploi et l'insertion
professionnelle alors je le disais il ya
un instant nous sommes au vélodrome
nationale pour ce premier en piste pour
l'emploi 200 entreprises présentes
jusqu'à 22 heures ce jeudi et pour
proposer donc 2000 offres d'emploi erwan
le gall on est ici dans le vélodrome
nationale une enceinte de sport
international futur théâtre des épreuves
de cyclisme sur piste pour les jo de
2024 c'est une excellente vitrine pour
l'emploi saint quentinois
alors c'est une magnifique vitrine je
leur ai juste de rectifier c'est pas de
mine mais quatre mille offres d'emploi
4000 voilà c'est important de le
préciser
oui oui c'est une belle vitrine déjà été
symbolique puisque
nous sommes comme dans le théâtre d'un
effort sportif très très conséquent donc
fournir l'effort pour l'emploi c'est
important et puis c'est le rayonnement
aussi au niveau du territoire de 50 ans
divine trouver un autre lui aurait été
difficile peut-être le théâtre mais
beaucoup moins grand beaucoup moins
accessible par rapport à tout ce que
nous proposons alors pourquoi organiser
ce grand événement ici finalement quels
sont les objectifs d'un tel événement
les objectifs d'un tel événement c'est
que nous avons fait le constat que sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
il y a toujours des forums pour l'emploi
mais à mesure plutôt petite part par
commune il est préférable de mutualiser
et être dans une synergie très forte sur
un lieu emblématique c'est à dire que le
fait de rassembler et de se rassembler
sur un tel lieu a permis aussi de
présenter un show room avec 150
entreprises d'avoir un ce qui recrutent
avec 2000 offres d'emploi plus de 1000
autres sur un autre secteur d'activité
d'accor avec une plate forme d'accueil
voilà justement saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien derrière
la défense ici seize mille entreprises
145 mille emplois le territoire regorge
d'atouts alors il regorge d'atouts nous
avons aussi un atout particulier c'est
que nous sommes à l'aune de paris saclay
donc c'est un tout c'est un ensemble et
un bassin économique très très fort très
très puissant
nous devons jouer ensemble et pas chacun
dans notre cour en a quand même au
niveau des biffins de la dynamique
économique
nous sommes quand même sur sur une
trajectoire très très forte très
puissante donc ne devons pas laisser
tout le monde sur le bord de la route et
on le voit ici il ya un centre numérique
il ya un certain nombre d'entreprises
diverses et variées mais que grands
groupes notamment implantés sur le
territoire il ya des grands comptes
évidemment il ya aussi
c'est juste pour finir mon propos allez
si il y à aussi j'ai entendu parce que
je suis allé j'ai passé toute
l'après-midi aller voir un des stands il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
services à la personne où il ya des
carences et il ya aussi des carences et
pas plus tard qu'il ya un quart d'heure
sur une entreprise au niveau des
ingénieurs donc on sent bien que l'écart
est très grand et on doit fournir tous
les efforts pour rassembler toutes nos
réussites au sein de ces entreprises et
grands comptes y compris un effort aussi
auprès des jeunes une mission locale
communaux douze communes de 5 en avril
il est le président d'ailleurs de cette
mission locale tafer qui est une mission
locale en ce nom mais art est mis sur le
calme et ce qui s'appelle skyway 16-25
qui a changé de nom justement pour
rentrer dans cette nouvelle dynamique
dans cette nouvelle démarche
alors ce jeudi donc au vélodrome
nationale jusqu'à 22 heures
quatre mille offres d'emploi 200
entreprises présentes qui sont l est est
ce que sarko ça recoupe plusieurs
secteurs d'activité oui il ya plusieurs
secteurs d'activités évidemment il y a
le secteur automobile
d'accord le secteur technologique
numérique services à la personne et j'en
passe et nous avons évidemment tous ces
grands comptes enfin j insiste bien là
dessus
question présent comment participer à
cet événement fallait s'inscrire à
l'avancé par y avait un téléphone alors
il y avait il ya deux je vais juste dire
deux choses la ville plate forme
d'inscription à ce jour là on est
presque à 4000 visiteurs à 18 heures
donc premier bilan c'est très serré ce
dont je voulais quand même dire que
cette réussite
la clé du succès c'est le travail le
fruit de travail de pôle emploi de saint
quentin en yvelines du département de la
région de l'ex mission locale donc ce
qui est 16 25 du prix de la cité des
métiers incertain un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui se sont mis autour de la
table et me qui ont travaillé il ya eu
un certain nombre de réunions mais des
pas des réunions pour réfléchir mais des
réunions pour faire et je tiens salut
mais comme toutes les équipes du dab et
côte saint quentin en yvelines qui ont
porté ça parce que savez je suis un élu
un peu particulier faut que ça aille
vite vite et bien et qu'on peut faire
vite mais mal mais on fait vite et bien
et
la réussite elle est là merci à toutes
ces équipes
alors si on parle de l'espace ici un
grand espace au vélodrome nationale qui
a été découpée en 5 univers
c'est ça que je voulais explique alesi
la wii est là la boussole à avancer pour
orienter le booster pourrait expliquer
aux gens un certain nombre de valeurs
pour retrouver un boulot monter un cv
être dynamique face à un employeur
savoir être sûr coiffure etc
il y à l'espace showroom il y avait là
nîmes emploi qui est ici et puis les
skis recrute l'animent emploi j'ai voulu
absolument qu'il y à un fil rouge
conducteur les témoignages tout au long
de la journée sur des chefs d'entreprise
des gens qui ont eu des échecs
professionnels mais qui ont su rebondir
l'apprentissage parce qu'il ya eu aussi
ce levier aussi de l'apprentissage et la
formation professionnelle on n'a pas
assez parlé mais ça a existé au niveau
du showroom y ait eu un certain nombre
45 centres de formation et il ya eu ici
des démonstrations et aussi des
explications qu'est-ce que
l'apprentissage un espace zen notamment
et un espace zen bonne ambiance le
hasard ce oui alors je l'épopée
vainement je n'ai pas encore eu le temps
d y aller alors peut-être avant la fin
de la journée à vendre avant le concert
voilà justement est le
l'événement va se terminer par une
grande fête un concert de rock ce soir
avec le groupe les boys voilà alors
l'époque sa particularité un sait pas on
se fait plaisir on fait un concert parce
que c'est la fête après la journée non
la particularité des boks se sont ils
ont tous un point commun ils se sont
tous connus à pôle emploi et ont créé
cette ce groupe de rock
voilà donc juste dans la symbolique je
trouvais que c'était fort et puis je
crois que tous les chefs d'entreprise
tous les formateurs et l'ensemble des
participants endroit un moment de
détente et surtout avant il ya le
networking où ils peuvent échanger leurs
cartes de visite discuter des prix fait
aussi de cette journée parce que moi je
l'entendais ensemble de choses il faut
que pour la deuxième édition du soyons
plus perspicace sur certains axes et
puis il ya toujours des choses à
améliorer
voilà ce qu'on l'a compris c'est un
événement qui va continuer dans le temps
merci à erwan le gall d'avoir été avec
nous merci d'avoir invité conseiller
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines délégué à l'emploi et à
l'insertion professionnelle et je vous
rappelle qu'en piste pour l'emploi c'est
ce jeudi 29 mars jusqu'à 22 heures au
vélodrome nationale on reste à saint
quentin en yvelines pour la suite de ce
journal spécial l'attend aura duré 11
ans pour l'ancien collège bergson à
montigny le bretonneux le site fermé
depuis 2007 vient d'entamer une phase de
déconstruction avant une démolition
totale du bâtiment dans les prochaines
semaines 136 logements seront érigées
sur place ainsi qu'un nouveau pôle
culturel un projet structurant comme
vous allez le voir avec ce sujet de
nicolas kirillovitch est difficile
d'imaginer qu'il y a une dizaine d'année
des élèves avaient cours entre ses murs
ou que des collégiens cours est ici à
l'heure de la récréation fermé en 2007
le collège bergson et désormais un vaste
chantier depuis le mois de janvier les
ouvriers sont les nouveaux maîtres des
lieux
cela nous terminons le désamiantage et
nous terminons également donc nous
sommes en plein curage c'est à dire que
vous enlevez ont toutes les cloisons
intérieures les doublages
la peau brune radiateur voilà pour qu'il
nous reste qu'à la fin que du béton une
véritable mise à nu du bâtiment donc qui
précède une démolition à partir du mois
de mai c'est alors que débutera la
véritable construction d'un projet phare
pour la ville promesses de campagne en
2014 le nouveau pôle culturel de quatre
étages l'installation des danseurs
musiciens et amateurs de théâtre est
prévue en 2020 dans des locaux
ultramodernes au coeur du quartier de la
sourde oreille
il est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
dans les locaux actuels tout ce qui est
sono et autres ne correspondent pas du
tout et parce que j'ai une certaine
vétusté donc là oui on aura une offre
complémentaire ou supplémentaires dans
des locaux vraiment adapté le nouveau
site verra aussi la construction de 136
logements répartis autour du centre
culturel coût net de l'opération pour la
ville 8 millions d'euros
la ville qui a lancé un concours
jusqu'au 1er juin pour trouver un
nouveau nom à l'établissement preuve
sûrement qu'une page se tourne à
montigny le bretonneux
en france environ 20% des étudiants
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté une
précarité qui peut mener à l'isolément
en deux ces jeunes c'est pour contrer ce
phénomène avec une agora et va voir le
jour à lui vs qu une convention a été
signée en ce sens ce mercredi la greule
est un lieu de vie au coeur de
l'université sur place une bibliothèque
participative des jeux de société
accessible gratuitement et aussi une
épicerie solidaire les étudiants
bénéficiaires pourront y faire leurs
courses à des tarifs très réduits 10 à
30 % par rapport au prix d'achat
classique des propos recueillis par
mélanie poké c'est un lieu qui répond à
la problématique de la précarité
étudiante par une réponse financière
parce que du coup les étudiants en
difficulté peuvent faire des économies
mais aussi par une réponse sociale
puisque en venant à l'agora ils vont se
rencontrer d'autres étudiants ils vont
vivre des tentes détendent ateliers ils
vont s'ouvrir et donc non seulement ils
réduisent leurs budgets mais aussi ils
rompent un peu leur isolement
d'étudiants difficultés financières on
n'a pas hésité parce que
à travers nos politiques pas une
priorité sur le développement de la vie
étudiante et puis d'une des actions
sociales qu'on peut apporter et on sait
que le phénomène de précarité des
étudiants et source d'échec et donc la
société agora et que l'université
soutient on lui fournissant des locaux
permet justement de réduire ce taux
d'échec
et puis d améliorer la vie étudiante de
manière générale le cetud journal depuis
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines ce jeudi 29 mars et la
première édition d' en piste pour
l'emploi et jusqu'à 22h autre événement
c'est ce week end juste à côté du
vélodrome au stadium international de
bmx est les deux premières manches de
coupe du monde 2018 de bmx supercross la
compétition sera diffusée d'ailleurs sur
tv 60 18 samedi
prise d'antenne à 18 heures et dimanche
c'est à partir de 16h et pour en parler
il n'est pas venu en vélo puisque les
locaux de la fédération française de
cyclisme sont juste à côté
c'est à michel callot bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de cette
fédération française de cyclisme alors
un vélodrome nationale les locaux de la
fédération ici sur place à saint quentin
en yvelines de nombreuses compétitions
aussi international avec cjo qui vont
arriver en 2024 on peut dire que saint
quentin en yvelines c'est la capitale du
cyclisme français
oui en tous les cas ça y ressemble
fortement et en termes d'installation
c'est vraisemblablement le cas notamment
à travers l'équipement dans lequel on se
trouve le le vélodrome olympique
le stadium de bmx qui va accueillir
effectivement ce week-end sa première
compétition internationale
alors ce stadium internationale au bmx
on le rappelle il est juste à côté du
vélodrome première fois qu'il accueille
donc cette cool coupe du monde alors
quelques éléments de présentation
d'abord cette coupe du monde la cette
manche qui va se dérouler à valence et
la saison de coupe du monde de bmx c'est
ça ben en fait effectivement on aura
même deux manches il le samedi et une le
dimanche jusqu'à quand et ce sont les
deux premières de la saison 2010 8 bmx
des vainqueurs par mange donc mais il y
aura un classement général à la fin de
la saison c'est ça qui sera établie
alors absolument il ya un classement
général sur l'ensemble des manches de
coupe du monde et en plus c'est une
tradition dans le cyclisme est un
championnat du monde qui discutent
discuter sur une course sèche d'une
seule journée
alors la soutiennent arrêtez moi si je
me trompe je crois qu'il aura plus de
250 athlètes
25 pays représentés on aura la crème de
la crème alors absolument et c'est même
la manche de coupe du monde de bmx
depuis que ces compétitions existe c'est
à dire depuis pas mal d'années
maintenant qui va regrouper le plus de
participants ce sont 290 participants
exactement qui vont s'affronter
d'ailleurs l'an passé c'est un français
silva andré qui a remporté le classement
général de cette coupe du monde de bmx
il se dit prêt pour renouveler cette
performance écoutez le au micro admical
et demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude
je me sens bien c'est la première course
de la saison s'est préparée aux états
unis au mois de février avec une grand
partie l'équipe de france donc voilà je
suis prêt je suis content d'avoir une
coupe du monde à la maison même si
j'habite 6 heures en bas mais voilà
c'est quand même la maison ici
le but ce sera d'être dans toutes les
finales et d'aller chercher les places
sur le podium après classement général
on verra voilà c'est une saison c'est
long c'est ces six épreuves
on va prendre une course une course at
the time cette année encore michel
callot là la délégation française a
toutes ses chances oui le bmx est une
discipline phare dans notre notre
fédération
on a quelques uns des meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux aussi bien chez les dames que
chez les hommes
et ça reste un gros potentiel pour pour
les jeux olympiques on travaille
beaucoup déjà en vue de tokyo 2020 cette
piste du stadium internationale dont qui
est juste à côté du vélo tu vélodrome
que pouvez-vous nous en dire c'est une
piste de très haut niveau qui est
présente ici alors c'est une piste très
haut niveau la caractéristique de ces
pistes et d'avoir une butte de départs à
8 mètres c'est particulièrement
spectaculaires ces très hauts cantons
accordant ce s'élancer à lui mettre deux
de hauteur
et puis surtout c'est le terrain dieu de
nos athlètes puisqu'on à d'autres pôles
france qui est basé ici au vélodrome
national avec notre équipe de bmx qui
s'entraînent tous les jours sur cette
piste alors un programme varié je vous
invite d'ailleurs à aller sur le site de
la fédération française de cyclisme pour
le trot retrouver ce sera une grande
fête du bmi sur a d'ailleurs un village
qui sera proposé en accès gratuit des
animations tout le week-end absolument
on a essayé de faire en sorte que ce
soit une grande fête du vélo une grande
fête autour de du bmx bien sûr et puis
la possibilité pour le public de nous
rejoindre jusqu'au dernier moment on a
encore quelques places qui peuvent être
vendus
les deux derniers jours donc n'hésitez
pas à nous rejoindre le plus nombreux
possible
un dernier mot ce genre d'événement
comme il ya eu les championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste ici en 2015 au
vélodrome ça sert de répétition générale
quand on sait que la legio arrive en
2024 ici à saint quentin en yvelines
oui en quelque sorte c'est une
répétition générale et puis surtout
c'est très important pour nos athlètes
d'avoir les plus grands événements
mondiaux à domicile chez eux c'est une
stimulation supplémentaire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle en fin de saison on
aura également une coupe du monde sur
piste
là où on se trouve dans ce vélodrome de
saint quentin merci michel callot
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
président de la fédération française de
cyclisme le début de cette coupe du
monde de bmx 2018 c'est ce week end au
stadium international de saint quentin
en yvelines infos et billetterie sur le
site de la fédération française de
cyclisme et cette compétition je le
rappelle elle sera diffusée sur tv 78
samedi prise d'antenne à 18 heures
dimanche c'est à partir de 16 heures
toute cette semaine tv 78 s'intéresser
aux métiers de la gendarmerie des
yvelines suite et fin ce soir de notre
dossier avec les référents sûreté leur
rôle donné à des conseils nécessaires
pour prévenir la délinquance auprès des
particuliers des entreprises ou des
commerçants ce jeudi matin la ferme de
coubertin à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse a
reçu la visite de professionnel camille
lambert était sur place pour lutter
contre le vol des engins et accessoires
donc il convient notamment de ne pas
laisser les clés sur le contact du
véhicule de ne pas non plus laissé dans
l'habitacle de bloquer le volant avec un
antivol mécanique des conseils qui
paraissent logiques mais encore trop peu
appliquées au quotidien rené est là pour
prévenir la délinquance en analysant les
situations à risque
aujourd'hui rendez vous à la ferme de
coubertin de saint rémy les chevreuse on
a eu un gros événement ici c'est un
incendie et donc suite à cet incendie
je les ai conseillé pour mieux sécuriser
pour mieux mettre en sûreté
leur exploitation agricole donc aussi
bien la partie bâtimentaire de véhicules
que effectivement la partie commerce
un incendie à l'été 2016 après un bilan
global le référent sûreté à proposer
différentes solutions aux agriculteurs
l'exploitation a donc débuté la
construction d'un mur de séparation
nous avons effectivement travaillé avec
le propriétaire des lieux pour que le
hangar ne soit pas coller à l'habitation
et pour qui une séparation visuelle
entre le matériel la spa ce matériel des
engins et le fourrage mais quelques
points sont toujours à améliorer
c'est avec isabelle caut exploitante de
la ferme que le gendarme poursuit sa
visite il conseille de mettre les anges
en sensible plus en retrait pourquoi
faudrait juste repenser peut-être
réorganisés effectivement rebouger oui
voilà vraiment là parce que des fois la
perte du temps de soir on va éviter
effectivement peut-être le vol de la
nuit éclairage à détection de mouvements
à proximité des zones sensibles panneaux
dissuasifs et construction du mur et des
assurances et du département la ferme a
investi entre vingt et vingt-cinq mille
euros pour sa sécurité
suite aux conseils du référent est
régulièrement ils viennent nous voir de
toute façon il parce qu'ils passent dans
la boutique où il passe voir mon frère
qui est plus dans l'exploitation on a
des très bons contacts avec eux pour
justement nous protéger au maximum et
protéger toutes les personnes qui
viennent sur l'exploitation la
prévention en milieu agricole de manière
générale sur les différents types de vol
les vols d'animaux l'an dernier dans le
département dix mille personnes
particuliers entreprises ont été
sensibilisés par ce service
actuellement les yvelines compte deux
référents sûreté un troisième est en
formation on parlait de tout à l'heure
de cette coupe du monde de bmx un autre
mot de sport avant de passer à autre
chose
ce dimanche 1er avril on joue les
demi-finales de la coupe des yvelines de
football et saint quentin en yvelines
est bien représentée avec trois clubs du
territoire encore en lice le derby
d'abord entre le leader de division de
district plaisir qui reçoit maurepas
actuels deuxièmes en d1 les plaisirs war
ont disposé au tour précédent elle de
maule maurepas de son côté est venu à
bout à des mureaux après une séance de
tirs au but
rencontre au stade bernard giroux de
plaisir à partir de et 15h coup d'envoi
à 15h également ce dimanche pour l'autre
demi-finale guyancourt accueil
hardricourt est les deux équipes
évoluent en d1 c'est le plus haut niveau
départemental en football au match aller
en championnat les deux formations
s'étaient quittées sur le score de 2
buts partout
le match est à suivre au stade maurice
baquet à guyancourt
on quitte ce vélodrome national
direction le domaine de rambouillet du
comte de toulouse fils du roi louis xiv
au président de la vème république
le domaine a toujours suscité l intérêt
des chasseurs un rapport aux sauvages
qui a trouvé l'écho dans une nouvelle
exposition
elle est au programme au centre des
monuments nationaux et au musée de la
chasse et de la nature
il accueille l'artiste julien
découverte avec mélanie poker et patrick
jacques de dixmude et des milliers de
paires la relier entre elles sur un
buste humain qu'on penserait presque à
un bijou cette créature est un serveur
un mélange entre un centaure la créature
mythologique et insère un vrai julien
mais l'imaginaire et le réel les
perles et la taxidermie sa force les
gens à se positionner
parce qu'en fait ils ont le choix entre
les deux extrêmes
moi je suis pas là pour donner des
messages je suis juste là pour donner
aux gens la possibilité se positionner
eux-mêmes dans leur propre imaginaire
pour moi cette pièce était un petit peu
celle qui me permettait de deux pauses
et de matières de manière un petit peu
sculpturale la question qui était de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on peut être à
la fois la proie est le prédateur
ce travail autour de la nature l'artiste
plasticien ne puise dans son héritage
familial
je lis un a été élevé dans la
contemplation des animaux sauvages mais
il se passionne aussi sur les croyances
et légendes que se créent les humains
comme ces yourtes inspiré des peuples
chaman chez eux en fait le corps il est
pas il n'est pas imperméable
y'a pas à l'intérieur et l'extérieur il
ya des jeux qui se jouent entre du coup
dans cette tour tant qu' couverte avec
des peaux de mouton et puis dépôt de
chevreuil vous avez 2
deux trous qui vous permettent de voir à
l'intérieur tout une installation en
fils tendus et en cloud éclairées à la
lumière noire
pour moi ce travail est un petit peu en
rapport avec avec la poésie des étoiles
on va dire donc c'est comme si en
regardant à l'intérieur du corps on
pouvait voir les étoiles qui sont les
éléments les plus lointains une
réflexion sur la violence de la mort de
l'animal exposé au sein d'un château où
les grands de l'histoire française se
retrouvaient pour chasser un bestiaire
fantasmagorique où l'artiste installe
une pointe de poésie avant de refermer
ce journal j moins 3 avant la fête de
pâques un moment religieux bien sûr mais
aussi un instant gourmand et les
chocolatiers des yvelines sont en ce
moment en pleine effervescence pour
l'une des périodes les plus importantes
de l'année pour leur activité i'm all
cette petite enseigne est installé
depuis 43 ans elle propose à des
créations qui mêle goût et design est
mise en bouche avec camille lambert et
michael et demi d'euros ici le chocolat
est considéré comme une oeuvre d'art la
chocolaterie cola ouverte depuis 43 ans
à maule propose des créations originales
pour la période de pâques l'entreprise a
choisi la thématique des graines un
univers imaginé dès la fin du mois de
janvier par les quinze artisans
chocolatiers la collection va se
construire avec tous les éléments qui
ont été créés comme ça à 3,4 pendant
plusieurs jours mais parfois en prenant
la forme que quelqu'un a élaboré avec la
texture que quelqu'un d'autre a
travaillé un petit accessoire complique
sur un autre sujet enfin on va vraiment
utiliser ce qu est ce qu'on a fait
pendant les 3/4 jour là comme de la
matière la matière est ensuite travaillé
à partir de la mi février pour répondre
à la demande dans le laboratoire les
créations sont décorés au pinceau
pendant plusieurs minutes avec une
peinture un peu particulière à base de
cacao
ça peut paraître un peu chaotique comme
ça mais c'est un petit peu comme un
combat peintre le beurre de cacao fait
office de rians et comme c'est comme la
peinture à l'huile
elle sauf que là ce qu'il faut fils lui
c'est le beurre de cacao on est à fondre
et on mélange des pigments type non
alimentaires donc là j'ai dû rouge le
mélange avec du blanc faire les
différentes nuances de couleurs et
ensuite je je je peins je peins mais
quid des figurines en chocolat sont
ensuite ajoutés pour correspondre la
thématique un décor imaginé en partie
par une ancienne étudiante en décor sur
céramique
je me suis mis à faire des grosses
fautes en tout premier si j'ai continué
à en faire et puis suis arrivé à faire
des petites têtes de série ont été
surveillés sur une recette qui séduit
pac représente près d'un tiers du
chiffre d'affaires annuel de
l'entreprise avec des créations qui se
vendent entre 10 et 100 euros
le chocolat continuera à couler à flots
jusqu'à la fin du week end
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal depuis
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une édition je
vous le rappelle à l'occasion de la
première édition adam pistes pour
l'emploi c'est ce jeudi jusqu'à 22
heures quatre mille offres d'emploi sont
proposées ici au vélodrome national 200
entreprises présentes et cet événement
qui se clôturera ce soir à 22h en fait
avec un concert de rock proposé par les
boys merci de nous avoir suivi on pense
également aux équipes techniques pour
leur travail du jour à suivre ce soir
sur notre antenne retour dans nos
studios avec le 7-8 débat demandeurs
bruyère rivera thématiques les réseaux
le réseau ferroviaire
quel avenir pour le train dont les
yvelines et ce journal je vous rappel
vous pouvez bien sûr le retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]